okay
thank you for taking the time to be here
good afternoon i'm accompanied by
jeff science who's heading up our whole
cova team
and uh today what i'd like to do is to
upgrade
up date you on where we are tomorrow
uh we're going to begin uh the
briefings going to occur on a regular
basis
with mr zions and his team so we're
bringing back the pros to
talk about covent in an unvarnished way
any questions you have
that's how we'll handle them because
we're letting science speak again
and so uh i i'd like to update you on
the aggressive steps we're taking to
meet our goal of administering 100
million cover 19 vaccine
shots within within 100 days
and to ramp up vamp the vaccine supply
as fast as we can
this will be one of the most difficult
operational challenges
we've ever undertaken as a nation i've
said that before but i must say it again
because we're going to do we're going to
do everything we can to get it done
but a lot of things can go wrong along
the way
and so i've as i've said in the past we
want to give credit to everyone involved
in this vaccine effort
and the prior administration and the
science community and the medical
uh sphere forgetting the program
i didn't do it i promise for getting the
program
uh off the ground and uh
that credit is absolutely due but it's
also no secret
that we have recently discovered in the
final days of the transition
and it wasn't until the final days we
got the kind of cooperation we needed
that once we arrived the vaccine program
is in worse shape
than we anticipated or expected a lot of
you follow this and nobody is
i mean necessarily the press is the
smartest group of people in town
you you hone this stuff down clearly
i think you found the same thing even
before i took office i announced a new
vaccine
a vaccination strategy which centers on
federal leadership and execution
for our whole country and that's why i
directed my cova team
to go to work immediately and how we
could step up the vaccination
efforts and the vaccinations i'm pleased
to announce
the first progress and that work today
and on day seven of my
my presidency first
after review of the current vaccine
supply and manufacturing plans
i can announce that we will increase
overall
weekly vaccination distributions of
states tribes and territories
from 8.6 million doses to a minimum of
10 million doses
starting next week that's an increase of
1.4 million doses per week
and you all know if i may know
parenthetically you all know
know that the vaccines are distributed
to states based on population
based on population and so the smaller
the state the less vaccine the bigger
the state the more they get
and uh so this can allow millions of
more americans to get vaccinated sooner
than previously anticipated we've got a
long way to go though the second thing
we're increasing the transparency with
states cities and tribes
and local partners when it comes to the
vaccine supply
this is something we've heard over and
over again from both democrats and
republicans
state and local leaders that they need
a plan in order to what they didn't know
what they have to plan on they need to
know what the order's going to be
jeff had a meeting with the governors on
zoom and uh
and and others and there i think we're
getting this coordinated in a way that
uh
there's increased uh cooperation and
confidence but until now we've had to
guess how much vaccine
to expect uh for the next week and
that's what the governors had to do how
much am i getting next week this is
unacceptable
the uh you know lives are at stake here
from this week forward god willing will
ensure that states tribes and
territories
will now always have a reliable
three-week forecast
what's the supply they're gonna get so
they'll know three weeks ahead of time
what's going to be there in the third
week
this is going to help make sure
governors mayors and local leaders
have greater certainty around supply so
they can carry out their plans to
vaccinate as many people as possible
so we will both increase the supply
in the short term by more than 15
percent
and give our states and local partners
more certainty about when deliveries
will arrive
these two steps are going to help
increase our prospects of
hitting or exceeding god willing the
ambitious goal
of 100 million shots in
100 days but i also want to be clear
100 million shots in 100 days is not the
end point
it's just the start we're not stopping
there
the end goal is to beat covet 19.
and the way we do that is to get more
people vaccinated which means
we have to be ready after we hit the
ground
he have to hit the goal of 100 million
shots
in 100 days now that means fewer than
100 million
people getting totally vaccinated means
100 shots
and it means somewhere between 60 maybe
less maybe more million people will have
that because it requires two shots
in many cases not always so today i'm
directing kova 19 response coordinator
jeff science here
to work with the department of health
and human services to increase our total
supply
of vaccine for the american people
and we believe that we'll soon be able
to confirm
the purchase of an additional hundred
billion doses
for each of the two fda authorized
vaccine pfizer and moderna
that's a hundred million more doses of
pfizer and 100 million more doses of
moderna
200 million more doses than the federal
government had previously secured
not in hand yet but ordered we expect
these additional 200 million doses to be
delivered
this summer and some of it will come as
early began to come in
early summer but by the mid by the
mid-summer
that this vaccine will be there and the
order
and and that increases the total vaccine
order
in the united states by 50 percent from
400 million
ordered to 600 million this enough
vaccine
to fully vaccinate 300 americans by
end of the summer the beginning of the
fall
but we want to make look that's i want
to repeat
it'll be enough to fully vaccinate 300
americans
to beat this pandemic 300 million
americans
and this is an aggregate plan that
doesn't leave anything on the table
or anything to chance as we've seen
happen in the past year
i've said before this is a wartime
effort
when i say when when i say that people
ask wartime
i say yeah more than 400
000 americans have already died i guess
411 or 12
have died in one year of this pandemic
more than all the people who died in all
the
americans who died in world war ii this
is a wartime undertaking it's not
hyperbole
and as such i directed the team to be
ready to exercise
all the authorities i have under the
defense production act
and expedite these vaccines and we're
using the defense production act to
launch
full-scale war time effort to address
the supply short
shortages we inherited from the previous
administration
we're going to be working across the
government with private industry to ramp
for production of vaccine
protective equipment the syringes the
needles the gloves the swabs the mask
everything is needed to protect test
vaccinate and take care of our people
well
we've already identified suppliers and
we're working with them to move
our plan forward the biggest problem i
hope you're all asking me
in by the end of the summer that you
have
too much vaccine left over you have too
much equipment left over
that's not my worry i hope that becomes
the problem
rather than we somehow find
interruptions in supply or access
these aggressive steps to increase
vaccine supply come on top of the steps
we took
last week to get more people vaccinated
for free
to create more places for them to get
vaccinated and to mobilize more medical
teams to get shots in people's arms
we've directed fema the federal
emergency management agency
to stand up the first federally
supported community vaccination centers
and that work is underway we're working
to make vaccines available to thousands
of local pharmacies
beginning in early february it's a
couple weeks off
and we know that will enormously expand
our reach
last week i also signed a declaration
to immediately begin reimbursing states
100 percent
for the uses of their national guard to
help a covert relief effort
both getting people you get getting the
sites set up
and even using some other personnel to
administer some of the vaccines
and i think it's something democrats
republicans governors alike have called
for
we're also expanding testing which will
help schools and businesses reopen
safely and protect the most vulnerable
and we formalize the health equity task
force
to ensure that equity is at the core of
everything we do in urban and rural
communities alike
to make sure those people most
significantly damaged
have have access access we have to
change we have to move in a direction
for those communities that are hard to
get to but the brutal truth is
it's going to take months before we can
get the majority of americans vaccinated
months
in the next few months masks
not vaccines are the best defense
against covet 19.
experts say that wearing masks from now
on just until april
would save 50 000 lives who otherwise
will pass away if we don't wear these
masks
that's why i'm asking the american
people to mask up for the first hundred
days
i've issued executive orders requiring
mass on federal property to interstate
travel trains and planes and buses
one congressman pointed out i could uh
i well he used a very anyway colorful
term to say
wearing a mask i tell them to kiss my
ear i'm not going to wear a mask
well guess what not very american the
fact
is you want to be patriotic you're going
to protect people
and new cover 19 variants are are
are are are we are instituting new
measures
to deal with these individuals flying in
the united states from other countries
you've all hold if you can hold a second
you all you've all heard about
the strain the the british strain
the brazilian strain the south african
strain
and they are they seem to be more
transmittable more easily
so in addition to wearing masks everyone
flying to the united states from another
country
we need to test before they get on the
plane
and self quarantine when they arrive in
america
i'm going to close with this i now have
a national we now have a national
strategy to beat cover 19.
it's comprehensive it's based on science
it's not politics
it's based on truth not denial and
it is detailed it's going to require
congress to pass the american rescue
plan
to provide funding to administer the
vaccines to ramp up testing
to help schools and businesses reopen
and deliver immediate economic relief
to americans who are in badly needed
through no
fault of their own and our plan
will take time progress from our plan
will take time to measure
as people getting infected today don't
show up in case counts for weeks
and those who perish from those from the
disease die
weeks after that exposure you know
despite the best our best intentions
we're going to face setbacks which i
will always explain to you and
acknowledge
and let me be clear things are going to
continue to get worse before they get
better
the death toll experts tell us is likely
to top 500 000
by the end of next month this february
and cases will continue to mount we
didn't get
into this mess overnight it's going to
take months
for us to turn things around but let me
be equally clear
we're going to get through this we will
defeat this pandemic
and to a nation waiting for action let
me be
clearest on this point help is on the
way
we can do this if we come together
if we listen to the scientists as i said
tomorrow i say to the press the entire
team will be back in the business
of my kova team of answering all your
detailed questions
so thank you very much for your patience
keep the faith we're going to get this
done
and i'll always level with you about the
state of affairs thank you
[Music]
um